(audience clapping)
One of my favorite movies
of all time is, "Coming To America"
"Coming to America 2"
is here and we can all finally go back to Zamunda.
Was there a moment where you said,
"Now is the right time to make the sequel?"
No, it kinda happened organically, this movie
the way it came together
because the way the story ended,
it was kind of like that...
It was and they live happily ever after.
And we didn't even think about making a sequel
but then the movie came like a cult movie
like little stuff from the movie.
The movie just stayed around.
Of all the movies that I've done,
none of them, no movie is on TV
as much as "Coming To America."
It's always on and little lines from the movie.
People have, "sexual chocolate."
People say that a little lines from the movie
or the mic drop that everybody does.
The mic drop,
the very first mic drop ever is Randy Watson
from "Coming To America.
And all this little stuff from the movie.
And then what happened about 10 years ago
people started...
Some people on Halloween would dress up as the characters.
and there's a restaurant in LA
that on Halloween changes itself into McDowell's
and they have like a McDowell's menu.
So it really is like this like cult movie, so it became that
and that's when I started having the idea of, you know
the people that really, really liked that movie
might want to see a sequel to it.
And then we, when we figured out a way to connect the dots
and then to make it make sense
then we wrote a script and it came together right.
Can I ask a burning question
that I've wondered ever since I first saw the movie,
which is the little child on the skateboard,
because they've all taken the suitcases
and they're wearing all the fabulous Zamunda garb.
Was it like, let's just say that we have so much clothes
that there are child sizes or screw it, tailor it, funnier
We were taking license there.
Cause I know as a kid
and he has on a little like their child side.
You have to remember now the movie was a comedy
and it was directed by the great John Landis
John Landis, that was people
when they talk about "Coming To America"
when I'm asked about "Coming To America"
they get me and our sineal look,
the actors they get all the credit for the movie
and that movie is
that movie is more John Landis than anything.
And that's a John Landis joke
to have the kids go skating by at the...
And in the moment he probably was like,
"Hey I have a kid skateboard right there"
(mumbles)
He's like that.
It's my favorite moment
other than, of course the quote of
"I have a date with Lisa"
and it's I say it every day
because it's my version of showing that I'm happy.
Aaww, that's wonderful.
(Drew laughs)
You know, that scene right there at
the little girls that are in that scene
was a friend of mine named Jeffrey Moore
who lived in Brooklyn
and he stopped by the set that day
and the little girl in the light blue jacket,
that was his daughter.
She was just with him.
We just put her in the scene like, right that
it just happened in that moment.
Would you ever say it with me?
Will you say it with me?
How do I say it like this
(chuckles)
"I have a date with Lisa"
(laughing)
Now I'll do it the right way
"I have a date with Lisa"
(laughter, clapping and cheering)
If I knew you was going to roll around
I'll have done it the first time
(laughter)
Eddie, I'm so happy to see you.
Thank you for giving me such incredible salient life advice.
It's nice to see you too.
And I look forward to after all this
pandemic stuff is over come and see you live in person.
(audience clapping and cheering)
I will roll myself up in this carpet for you.
I'll be like a burrito by the time we finish
and I will dance that victory dance
and recognize the purpose and--
If you could do it physically do it,
get ready to do always start the day with
I've already won this,
at this game I've already won.
Now it's just about
getting the most out of everything,
being here and your babies and your family.
I very much recognize that
and I love it coming from
the person who has made life makes sense
for so many of us on this planet
by helping us love and laugh and enjoy life
and fall in love with the extraordinary characters
that are you
that you've put out into the world.
Thank you.
Thanks so much
(audience cheering)
"Coming 2 America" is now available globally
on Prime Video.
(upbeat music)